big story about Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton's remarks during paid speeches
to Goldman Sachs and Deutsche Bank and
Morgan Stanley and other groups and
banks were leaked over the weekend by
WikiLeaks and Julian Assange the
excerpts are revealed in an email uh
that was written to John Podesta the
campaign chairman for Hillary Clinton
now I have to tell you I think the
Republicans messed up this entire speech
thing because there are statements from
these emails which confirm what we all
knew Hillary Clinton is a center-left to
center right status quo plutocratic
Democrat and we knew that already and
for example there is a quote of Hillary
Clinton admitting that she's out of
touch because she's been rich for a long
time Hillary Clinton saying you need to
have a private in public position on
policy Hillary Clinton making comments
that are not hugely anti trade deal
what's surprising about this this has
been my critique of Hillary Clinton all
along talking about middle-class
anxieties Clinton said I'm kind of far
removed from that because my husband and
I have lived a pretty privileged
economic life for a while talking to
goldman sachs bankers saying that it's
necessary to involve the industry
because people in d in the industry know
best about what should be done within
the industry that is a very deferential
comment to Wall Street and Goldman Sachs
but we knew that we knew that and that
is something we knew about Hillary
Clinton she gave a speech in April of
2013 to Morgan Stanley out where she
praised the simpson-bowles
deficit-reduction plan which would
reduce corporate tax rates and raise the
Social Security age this is exactly what
we've known about Hillary Clinton for
years remember the leaked audio from
last week where she says I see myself
occupying center left to Center right
center left right putative progressivism
is basically status quo corporate
plutocrats who are socially liberal
that's what we're dealing with here
Hillary Clinton is completely
predictable she'll do some seemingly
progressive things under the social
issues umbrella things will be basically
Attis quo with regard to most areas of
the economy and financial regulation and
foreign policy will be moderately
neoliberal everything in these speeches
confirms that there are no bombshells in
these speeches unless you've not been
paying attention and I actually read
more of the emails than just what was
cherry picked by some people and there's
actually stuff in there also that really
isn't bad i mean Hillary Clinton there
there's a quote which all put up for you
here where Hillary Clinton actually said
that we have to recognize uh that we
have to rely on the markets transparency
and integrity even if it may not be one
hundred percent true if the perception
is that somehow the game is rigged that
should be a problem for all of us and we
have to be willing to make that
absolutely clear if there are issues if
there's wrongdoing people have to be
held accountable and we have to try to
deter future bad behavior that's Hillary
Clinton to Deutsche Bank not exactly
saying I don't care what Wall Street
does here's another example from these
emails which is really not that bad
here's Hillary Clinton talking about
health care and health insurance saying
if you look at countries that are
comparable like Switzerland or Germany
for example they have mixed systems they
don't have just single-payer but they
have very clear controls over budgeting
and accountability if you look at the
single-payer systems like Scandinavia
Canada and elsewhere they can get costs
down because you know although their
care according to statistics overall is
as good as better or on as good or
better on primary care in particular
they do impose things like waiting times
it takes longer to get like a hip
replacement then it might hear this is
not exactly right but this is not crazy
right-wing talk and I think Pat that
this backfired because what republic be
anga lon this should have been hillary
got rich giving speeches to banks based
solely on being a politician that's
really that the critique I would make
but Republicans can't make that critique
because they get rich the same way and
the content of these emails I've been
paying attention this is exactly what we
expected about Hillary
absolutely and she uses kind of coded
deliberate language she does it kind of
subtly you uh but she's still
communicating the message that she's not
gonna rock the boat and she's not going
to be a proponent of change for the sort
of thing when we look at what Hillary
Clinton has said to the public it's
abundantly clear that she is a status
quo moderate politician slightly to the
left of moderate Republicans when we now
see what Hillary Clinton said to the
wall street firms and the banks etcetera
we see that yes she uses a slightly
different vocabulary when talking to
them but even still she is completely
predictable in terms of what we can
expect with Hillary Clinton is press
president do I champion this do I am I
blind to the reality that Hillary
Clinton is not a progressive Democrat of
course not of course not but if you were
counting on bombshells from these
speeches that has now been completely
deflated and I don't know what we're
going to get out of these speeches that
we didn't already know and i think that
Republicans now have absolutely nothing
because number one they are guilty of
all the exact same stuff to a worse
degree and number two they can't
critique the fact that she did the
speeches because they do the exact same
thing